Hey everyone, I'd like for you to take a moment and think back to the last time you saw something marked down from $100 to $75.
Even if you didn't need it, it felt like a deal.  Right?
Your reaction isn't purely rational, it's psychological.
And that's what we're going to be looking at in this video, psychological pricing.
We're going to explore how behavioral biases shape pricing strategy.
So we're going to go a little bit beyond some of the theory here and look into the minds of the customers.
Look, lets start with what psychological pricing is.
It refers to using human biases and heuristics to influence how people perceive value and make purchasing decisions.
One of the most important concepts here is loss aversion.
This is when people feel the pain of losing something more strongly than the pleasure of gaining something of equal value.
In pricing.  This means customers are highly sensitive to perceived losses, but may respond more favorably to to discounts, deals and bundles that frame pricing in terms of savings or avoidance of loss.
So in this case, what we see here is loss aversion in action.
We have a person who has a loss and they perceive it as a bigger loss than the person who has a gain.
So let's move on to a few types of psychological pricing that we can deal with.
The first is anchoring.
This is the cognitive bias where individuals rely too heavily on on the first piece of information that is the anchor.
When making decisions.
People rely on that first number that they see.
The first number becomes a reference point.
It's their anchor.
In this case we have a jacket that was listed at $120 but then marked down to 75.
So this seems like a great deal because the 120 sets the expectation.
So as far as a pricing strategy is concerned, you start with the high list price and then you discount it to make it look like a bargain, even if the final price is the standard price.
Let's move on.  Now we have left digit bias.
This is a price in effect where consumers give disproportionate weight to the leftmost digits of a price.
This is a classic example of the 499 versus $5 question or situation.
Even though the difference is just $0.01, it feels like a lot more.
So here we have two candy bars.
$1 one's 99 cents and the one that's 99 cents is going to sell better.
So our strategy Here is Use $0.99 or 0.99 or 0.95 endings to make prices appear lower, especially for low involvement or impulse buys.
Our next is the decoy effect.
This occurs when a third less attractive option influences buyers to prefer a specific choice among the original options.
So adding a third less attractive option can influence which product people choose.
Here we have three coffees, a small, medium and large.
The smallest $3 medium, $6 and the largest $7.
People are going to flock to the large because the medium makes the large like a better deal.
So here our strategy is create tier pricing to nudge customers towards the higher margin product.
Our next is framing.
Framing is the way information is presented to emphasize gains or losses, impacting perception and decision making.
So how you describe a price matters as much as the number itself.
For example, we have two people here.
One's telling us that we can save $20 a month and the other one is telling us don't lose $240 this year.
It's the same amount of money either way, but we framed it a little bit differently.
Now the second one feels a little bit more urgent because it frames the outcome as a loss.
And remember, this goes back to loss aversion.
So our strategy here is emphasize avoided losses to trigger stronger emotional responses.
And our last psychological pricing technique that we're going to look at is endowment effects.
This is a bias where people place higher value on things they already own or they feel that they own.
People value things more once they feel ownership, even if they haven't bought it yet.
So here we're going to give you a seven day free trial on this premium app and that's going to lead to more subscriptions.  Why?
Because users don't want to give up what they've already started using.
This goes against the sunk cost fallacy, but that's a part of the irrational behavioral aspect that we're talking about here.
So our our strategy is going to be offer trials, samples or onboarding experiences that help build attachment before the actual purchase.
So while none of these pricing strategies work purely because of the math, they all work because of the psychology behind them.
If you understand how people are going to perceive price, you can shape not just what they are going to pay, but you can also shape how they're going to feel about paying for it.  And that is it.
Hope you've enjoyed it.